tengo cerca de 21 años trabajando para
la secretaria de seguridad pública
puesto mi profesión al servicio de los
compañeros policías y las compañeras
policías custodios de seguridad pública
este gusto de penitenciarios perdón y
todas las personas que están
relacionadas con esto
a través de este tiempo he aprendido
muchas cosas sobre todo a verlos como
humanos a veces se nos olvida que el
policía también tiene familia que
también tiene hijos esposa papá mamá y
lo vemos como el hombre que le gusta
verse o la mujer que le gusta verse
fuerte valiente y valeroso bueno me
gustaría esta conferencia que fuera un
reconocimiento al trabajo que han hecho
mis compañeros y al esfuerzo que hacen
allá afuera todos los días para poder
compartirles lo que esta noche he estado
esté practicando este es un ensayo nada
más que vamos va para poder comentarles
y mandar a introducción les voy a contar
una historia muy sencilla
he escuchado ustedes también que en
áfrica las casas son redondas y en los
techos de paja verdad
nos vamos a ubicarnos en un lugar de
estos resulta que en una tarde
cualquiera en una de las plazas estaban
dos lagartijas peleándose en áfrica las
lagartijas se llaman más joyas y hacen
unos ruidos así como como qqqq bueno
estaban estas lagartijas peleándose y
pasa un perro y las ve y les dice por
favor no se peleen
no podemos permitir violencia de este
pueblo aquí todos tienen que vivir en
paz por favor se parece que se parece en
las lagartijas obviamente no lo peleaban
entonces ya se llena en su proyecto el
cuco dijo qué puedo hacer aquí no
podemos vivir así ya sé voy a buscar
ayuda y fue a buscar al gallo dijo el
gallo es valiente tiene huevos o sea de
las gallinas para las cuida y me va a
ayudar y entonces le dijo un gallo
hay dos lagartijas perdiéndose en el
pueblo tenemos que venir corre vamos a
ayudarle yo hay que separarlas no
podemos vivir violencia institucional ni
violencia de ningún tipo y al gallo le
dijo a ver express express yo voy a ir a
separar las lagartijas lo siento yo
cuido a mis gallinas mis huevos james
entonces el perro deseando puede ser
posible alguien me tiene que ayudar ya
fui a hablar con las lagartijas si no me
hacen caso se le se le atraviesa por ahí
el el asno y le dice más no hay dos
logotipos poniendo son del pueblo tienes
que venir a ayudarme
mientras las lagartijas estaban tutu
pérez entonces el asno dijo ya perdón yo
trabajo son tus amigas no entonces
quieres que yo me voy a meter a separar
a dos lagartijas que ni tus amigas son
verdad yo necesito descansar porque o
sea trabajé mucho y se fue y entonces el
perro seguía preocupado por cómo íbamos
a separar a las lagartijas y dijo pues
voy con el buey por grandote y con la
voz y con todo esto que tienen los
bueyes este pues me va a ayudar a
separar las lagartijas pues no tampoco
porque le dijo ese año cómo voy a ir a
ayudarte a separar
artistas que se están peleando ahí no
hay nos vemos o sea yo estoy para otras
cosas
entonces pues las lagartijas tuk tuk tuk
tuk tuk seguían peleando subieron a el
techo de paja en la revuelta que traían
se cayó una de ellas adentro estaba una
abuelita cocinando se caía el aceite el
aceite incendia la casa este tratan de
salvar a la abuela y agarran al burro
para que cargue el agua pero cuando
apagan al incendio pues la abuela ya se
había muerto entonces en áfrica las las
personas que mueren mayores pues merecen
un sepelio de tres días y para esto hay
que darle de comer a los que a los que
van a acompañarla pues ya sabrán se
echaron al gallo se echaron al buey el
asno estaba cansadísimo y el perro le
dijo ya ves buey o sea me hubieras
ayudado a separar las lagartijas esto no
habría pasado
y ahí vamos a dejar la historia cada día
las personas sentimos que la inseguridad
está más cerca de nosotros y está más
cerca de nosotros es cierto porque yo no
sé si es que hay más medios de
comunicación o nosotros tenemos más
gente cerca que está viviendo esta
violencia o no sé qué pasa pero los
sentidos chris horner es un
[Música]
y conferencista y es un consultor de los
ángeles y él dice que la calidad de vida
de las personas depende de la seguridad
que sienten entonces si nosotros
queremos tener calidad de vida nos
tenemos que sentir seguros con las
situaciones que se están viviendo en
este país con lo que se ha vivido este
fin de semana en este estado pues
difícilmente nos podemos sentir seguros
la policía
hace lo que puede porque sus políticas
públicas son creadas para otro tipo de
situación
cuando vemos muchos policías nos da una
sensación también de temor pero si yo te
pregunto que cómo puedo yo garantizar tu
seguridad me vas a pedir más policías
más patrullas más armas y cuando las
tenemos cuando los vemos pasar juntos en
convoy nos da miedo porque creemos que
algo malo está pasando y eso nos genera
más inseguridad entonces no sabemos cómo
para dónde darle
cuando las armas y los policías están a
la disposición no están solucionando
estas políticas que desafortunadamente
muchas veces se hacen desde el
escritorio las políticas las diseñan a
veces personas que no tienen un contacto
con el compañero que está afuera y que
es el que se tiene que enfrentar a las
situaciones de alto impacto lo hace una
persona que no se sienta a platicar con
la víctima para preguntarle qué necesita
y desde donde la tenemos que ayudar
entonces las políticas no son tan malas
solamente están un poco mal encaminadas
algunas porque finalmente lo que se hace
aún desde el escritorio es funcional
hasta hoy pues ha funcionado quizás hay
políticas que tendríamos que cambiar
esas políticas que no son tan humanas
que no son tan sensibles necesitan ser
contactadas con materias o con o con la
ciencia como la psicología la sociología
la antropología no podemos o no están
padres seguir teniendo políticas que
solamente repriman o que solamente hagan
presencia necesitamos ver cuál es el
problema de origen el problema de origen
muchas veces es que las personas nos
preocupamos pero no nos ocupamos cuántas
veces nosotros hemos propuesto o hemos
hecho algo en casa para sostener o para
soslayar estas estas políticas
la para mí la mejor política es la que
se gesta en la casa justamente y somos
los papás quienes los vamos este las
vamos diseñando este es un tema que es
de todos los días en la mesa de su casa
para saber cómo salimos a la calle para
saber cómo nos enfrentamos para no dejar
que el miedo nos encarcelen en nuestra
propia casa si se fijan cada vez hay más
tiendas más este casas llenas de de
cámaras y estás llenas de tiendas que
están enrejadas porque tienen miedo aún
a un ataque a veces la inseguridad se
contagia con el de al lado no nos ha
pasado nunca nada pero dicen que andan
levantando dicen que está sucediendo
dice y no hacemos a la mejor algo más
que activismo de escritorio y entonces
pasamos todos los links y todos
los comentarios en facebook en twitter y
en todos en todas las redes sociales
pero nadie se acerca a preguntar si es
cierto también es cierto que nadie de
este lado sale a decir tranquilas no es
este como lo estamos viviendo no es
siempre este una situación de crimen
organizado no es si explico no no no
entendemos porque no nos explican tal
vez entonces nada más nos preocupamos
pero no nos ocupamos más allá de lo que
necesitamos hacer
dice también por ahí que las personas
nos empezamos a sentir cercanas y nos
empezamos a sentir seguras cuando vemos
que los demás también están seguros y
cercanos entonces los valores hoy en día
no han cambiado los valores hoy en día
es necesario que sean adecuados a la
época que tenemos yo no puedo decirle a
mi hija que pierda el respeto a un
adulto pero tampoco le puedo decir que
le cree a todo porque la vulneró
entonces necesitamos irnos adecuando les
cuento para finalizar lo que pasó este
después de que ya quemaron alas se
murieron las lagartijas y la abuela y
todo dice el que narra la fábula que en
ese pueblo lo que necesitaban hacer era
preocuparse antes de ocuparse antes de
preocuparse qué es lo que le pasa a la
minoría es un problema de la mayoría que
no podemos ir por la vida haciendo
sumiso y esperando que el gobierno o las
instituciones resuelvan nuestras
situaciones de seguridad porque ésta
empieza en casa en casa es donde tenemos
que empezar a desarrollarlas es cierto
que el gobierno el estado es el que el
que debe de garantizar la seguridad pero
en esta vida no hay nada garantizado
sobre la muerte
todos somos pasajeros de un mismo tren
cambiamos nada más de andenes pero
seguimos en el mismo tren si fuéramos un
poquito más solidarios y empáticos que
no es lo mismo yo creo que las cosas
empezarían a transformarse no sé si es
mejor o peor no sé si para bien o para
mal pero empezarían a transformarse y
entonces empezaríamos a ver este cambio
que estamos anhelando que se dé desde
arriba cuando muchas veces lo tenemos
que empezar a gestar desde los más
cercanos a nosotros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]